- [Announcer] Middle Ground
is a social experiment
that brings humans with opposing beliefs
or experiences together.
These discussion may contain viewpoints
that are the result of misinformation.
Remember to seek out
experts and to be critical
of your own biases while
forming an opinion.
Please see the humanity
in each participant,
and as always, we encourage empathy.
- Two things can be true.
You can have had a very hard time.
Privilege is not just
limited to white people.
But to say white privilege doesn't exist,
from historical context, to me,
is respectfully absurd.
(pensive, enlightening music)
- [Moderator] Step forward
if you agree with the prompt.
White people also experience racism.
- I think racism is
definitely not a one race
against the other.
It goes all ways.
It doesn't matter if you're
white, if you're black,
if you're Asian, it doesn't matter.
You could experience racism
no matter what color your skin is.
- I think that people have a propensity
to kind of have an aversion
towards what's different from them.
I've been called a cracker before.
I've been told I was
going to get beaten up
because I was white.
I would argue that on a systemic level,
white people don't experience racism
the same way a lot of other
races experience racism.
But I would say on an individual level,
any group is capable of being racist
towards another group as well.
- So the argument against
this position frequently is
that racism is a system, not a sentiment
in the United States.
And I agree with that really strongly.
But at the same time, I'm Jewish.
I'm racially white.
And I've definitely experience
racism, discrimination.
The paradox is that most of that racism
is coming from white
people or European society,
white nationalism, et cetera,
that's directed at Jews.
I'm Dane, and I'm Jewish.
I'm proud of being Jewish
and being connected an an
ancient religion and culture.
But I'm not proud to be white I would say.
White privilege, I think, is
an aspect of American society.
I think it exists.
When I go to a job interview,
I don't have to worry about my hairstyle
or the way I normally speak or my name.
And that's something
perhaps a Black person
would have to worry about.
- [Moderator] Can the
disagreers step forward?
- So I just wanna say
that I want to validate
everyone's individual experiences.
I do also believe
that white people
experience bias, prejudice.
But the reason I did not step forward
is because by definition,
racism is tied to power and economics.
You talked about systemic discrimination.
I don't feel white
people experience racism
by definition and by actual concept.
- What is the definition of racism
and who wrote that definition?
- In the late 1500s, early 1600s,
there was slavery, they
started bringing over slaves.
But there was really no
concept of classifying people
in terms of race.
It's just we're bringing these people over
and they're slaves.
What ended up happening is
some of the slave owners,
who were white, started mixing
with some of the slaves.
And now here you have these Black people
that look like the people
that are owning things.
So they're like, whoa, whoa, whoa.
The theory of race was formed
to classify a group of people
who would be lesser than and
have less economic power.
And this would be imposed against them
for hundreds of years.
So that has not been the white
experience in this country.
But it does not invalidate the things
that white people experience.
It's just not racism by definition.
Is it prejudice, is it
bias, is it wrong, yes.
- Mine is simple.
If one person treats
another person differently
because of the color of their skin,
to me, that's racism.
I will tell you that I
was stopped by the police
plenty of times when I was a young man.
And I will also tell
you that I then decided
to spend 35 years as a policeman.
I'll tell you that I stopped lots of kids
coming home from school.
Depending who it was that I stopped,
the first thing out of
their mouth would be,
"You only stopped me because I'm Black."
And I would say,
"You're driving a sports car
with a window that's this big.
I can't see who's driving.
And I stopped you because
you're doing 95 in a 55.
I had no idea who I was pulling
over until I stopped you."
Now, if I treat you differently
because you're Black,
then I'm a racist.
But if I write you the same ticket
that I was gonna write you
before I knew who was
behind the wheel, I'm not.
- So I'm glad you used that example,
and I want to commend you for
your service to our country.
But I do want-
- But.
- But I do wanna say,
'cause I've actually
taught classes for the LAPD
and for their cadets about these issues.
But what I can say, which is a statistic,
and which is also a fact,
is that 60% of our prison population
is African American-
- Different issue.
- Yes, but let me finish, please.
Is African American males, right?
When you go into a system
and you are kept in that system
and you're cycled through probation
and there is a systematic
sequence of oppression,
that's not happening to white males.
So it's bigger than just the stop itself.
It's the system.
My name is Sierra.
I'm an actor, a speaker,
and a human rights activist.
I'm very proud to be African
American, to be Black.
The challenges that come with being Black,
also being a Black woman, are very real.
I'm at a place in my life
where I'm acknowledging
these things are real.
Discrimination is real.
The systematic oppression of
Black people is very real.
But I will succeed in spite of that.
- [Moderator] The police force
is foundationally racist.
- I want to start off by saying
I don't think that every cop
out there today is racist.
- Same.
- Yes.
- I think there are a lot of them
who are really doing good work.
But I know from the
establishment of the policing
in the United States
that is directly from the slave catchers
who were hired to catch runaway slaves
and bring them back home.
- Yeah, I agree that
all cops aren't racist.
I had plenty of interactions
with police that were fine.
But I was told by a former police officer
who was a cop who decided he
didn't wanna do that anymore
that the training is
pretty much specialized
for only colored people,
especially Black people,
that if you're around them,
they're the most dangerous
so you have to act in certain situations,
or react to certain situations.
- I think that I just
really want to emphasize
that I really think that
there are some officers
who are white that don't even believe
that they're doing anything
that may be racially motivated
because they're simply doing
what they were taught to do.
- I come from a police family.
And I'd like to add they do offer
diversity trainings in the academy.
So either it needs to be more extensive.
Or maybe we need to take it a step back
and fix the selection process,
because that process could
be inherently racist.
- Hello, my name is Nia, and I am Black.
I'm proud of my race because
when I look back historically
at what people of my
heritage have gone through
and to see where we are
now, it's remarkable.
And it definitely pushes me
to continue to be resilient
and innovative as they were.
- Historically, people
formed groups, villages.
Some people were hunters,
some people were farmers.
And then you had whoever
was gonna protect the group.
And over hundreds of
years, thousands of years,
whatever it is, that's
how we wind up having
cops, firemen, armies, and navies.
Community policing as a
theory is a good idea.
As a practice, it has some hiccups.
When I show up at your house
because you and your husband got into it
and he beats you up
and I'm friends with him.
So do I want to take him to jail?
He's my friend.
Or I live in the same neighborhood
and I go deal with some
guy who's a really bad dude
and he says, "I know where you live.
I know where your kids are."
So to some degree, we have
to have a little separation.
This is gonna get into a hot button topic.
But I will tell you that when
I watched the horrible video
of George Floyd, I will
tell you that I can justify
many of the things that happened,
but I cannot justify nine
minutes on his neck or back.
But what I can also tell you
is that I as a policeman,
and this is my personal opinion only, too,
the officer who was on
him for nine minutes,
he probably spent too much
time in the same neighborhood
dealing with the same
problems over and over again,
that he became jaded.
- Isn't that was being
a police officer is?
- It's a social service job.
- That's the job.
- And you're assigned to that
district or that community.
- But I think you need to move around
so that you get to see other things,
you don't become that jaded.
- The police, no matter what your race is,
we have to be integrated all
together with the community.
It doesn't have to be community policing.
But we all have to
understand each other more.
I think cultural competency
would be very helpful.
Like, that's my issue.
Whether or not the foundations
of the police force
was or still is, was racist,
now we can change that.
But it starts with cops.
Like, at the end of the day,
it's the bad police
officers that are issue.
Not all police officers,
but the bad police officers,
we need to vet them out.
And the good police officers,
we need to encourage them
to be amongst the community.
- How do we vet them out?
- By making the police unions accountable.
Because I feel like that
demographic of officers,
they're actually making things a lot worse
for the other officers
that are actually just trying-
- Absolutely.
- to do their job.
I think we need to get some
type of real accountability
that I don't think the police
should be policing themselves.
So when those cops that aren't doing
according to their oath,
they can be properly removed
instead of getting all of these passes.
- The bad police
officers, I hate the term.
Like the bad apple.
It's like, no, you're a faulty grenade.
Like you are ruining your
whole department reputation.
I feel like I was held
up to a higher standards
working at Whole Foods sometimes.
I got three chances, (snap) out.
But Derek had so many-
- 17 reports before
George Floyd.
- 17 reports!
- It's like get him out of there!
What are you guys doing?
- Do you think police officers,
and I genuinely am curious.
Do you think they should get paid more?
- I think police officers
should get paid more.
I also think police
officers should do less.
Why do I get sent to all
of the mental health cases?
Why do I get sent
- I agree.
to all off these things.
Now, I'll tell you why I get sent to them
is because we'll stop
sending the police there
and then something horrible
and tragic is gonna happen
and they're gonna say, "Why
didn't we have a cop there?"
- Do you think we need to
have different divisions,
like mental health, and just other,
or maybe even specific police
that are just for the schools?
Do you think that would help
with a lot of the issues?
- No, we do have
specialized police officers
in certain things.
But if we keep specializing
and we get so compartmentalized
that I can't go, I'm right
across the street from you
when you're screaming for help.
- Oh, I see what you're saying.
- Yeah, that's not what I do.
Gotta find the guy that
deals with screaming women,
or whatever it is.
My name is Jimmy,
and I am a retired police officer.
I'm not gonna tell you
that there are no racists
on the police department.
I don't think Blacks were
historically treated fairly
under the law.
I think that we have made
great progress, great strides.
I think we have to continue to get better.
But I also think we probably
see racism to this day
in places where it maybe isn't.
- [Moderator] I sometimes
wish I was a different race.
- I'd say not so much these days,
but definitely 100% when I was a kid,
I wished I was white.
I grew up with my white mom
and I didn't see my
Black side of my family
after a certain point.
I grew up in a small town.
I was often the only student of color,
definitely the only Black kid.
And I had this kinky hair.
I couldn't figure out how to work with it.
And everybody also would call me an Oreo.
It was always just being othered.
And so being a kid, you know,
you just want to fit in.
And for me, I wanted to be white.
I just wanted to look like my mom,
I want the nice straight hair,
and I just wanted to feel, like, included.
- Yeah, like I remember
in elementary school,
like I was thinking, no
man is ever gonna like me
because I freaking look like this.
And I just remember hating my hair
'cause as soon as puberty hit,
it was just (blows out forcefully).
It just blew up.
And people kept on asking,
"Do you even need a
pillow to sleep at night?"
I'm like, I can't stand these questions.
I can't do this.
I'm Jordan, and I am biracial.
I think being biracial is definitely
like living in the in-between
because culturally, yes I grew up white
and I completely know that.
Like I was raised by my white mother.
But then there's also a part
where race is perceived.
And it's what people put on you
and how they respond to
you in your everyday life.
- It's so interesting because I grew up
in predominantly non-Black communities.
And for some reason, still,
like being the minority,
at home in the family as
well in school and the world,
I was always so proud to be Black.
I actually really yearned to
be around other Black people.
So thankfully in college,
that was an experience
where even though we made
up a small community,
I was still able to, okay, this
is like people look like me.
- I was in the military for six years.
And I was usually the
only Jew in my battalion.
And I think that isolation produced
a sort of pride and
understanding of who I am
and where I come from.
- I have never wanted
to be anything different
than what I was.
But that's because I really
never thought about it.
And to your old point,
maybe, I don't know,
but maybe people treated you that way
because there is this
sense of wanting something
that I haven't ever had before.
I'd love to have a Lamborghini.
You know what I mean?
It's different than any
other car I've ever had.
It's different than what I grew up with.
- I think personally for me,
I mean, I was actually
adopted by white parents
in a very diverse family.
I think six out of the
eight of us are all adopted,
all different races.
I kind of have my own story
apart from everyone else.
And the same for everyone else
that's adopted in my family,
they have their own story.
I always have pride in
it, but at the same time,
my parents are my parents,
no matter the color of their skin.
It's the people who raised me.
They raised me to just not look at it
through the lens of racism.
That's what I've always done.
And I never wanted to
change my race at all.
- I'm Joshua and I'm Black.
I've never experienced racism.
I've experienced stuff from
people from my own race.
I grew up in a white
family by white parents.
I was constantly called white-washed.
It upset me, but I
didn't let it get to me.
Being Black in America to me is just being
an American in America,
just like any other person.
- [Moderator] White privilege exists.
- I mean, America was
founded by white people
for white people at the time.
All of the institutions were designed
to benefit white people.
So I mean, of course
white privilege lingers
into society today.
We can't deny that.
- Where I would argue with
you just a little bit is
I think we throw out
the term white privilege
far too often for things
that aren't necessarily white privilege.
- I got to agree with
you complete on that one.
I think there's generational
white privilege for sure.
But I think now it's
almost used as a reason
to not try as hard.
If we stop doing that, just
like really work for it
and not use white privilege as an excuse,
then we could really get
somewhere in the Black community.
- I would respectfully disagree.
Like, all of that is true to an extent.
Like, I graduated university
during the pandemic,
the height of it.
I went abroad for university.
I got two degrees.
I graduated with honors.
I learned to speak two languages.
Should have been able to
get a job right away, right?
No, it took me nine months
before I was able to get a job.
Had to go completely outside of my field.
But then when I looked at
all of my white colleagues
who are in my program,
all of them were hired immediately.
- I need to introduce you to my daughter.
She's white, took her a long time
out of college.
- And I'm not saying that.
- I'm saying that-
- She didn't get her job
in what her degree is in either.
- I respect that, but my point is saying,
me comparing myself to the white students
who were directly in my position,
they're successful, I'm not.
- This country was founded
upon white people coming
and then putting in act
Jim Crow and other laws,
saying that if you are not white,
you are genetically inferior.
You are not even a person.
And some of those laws are still,
and those systems are
still in place today.
Two things can be true.
You can have had a very hard time.
Privilege is not just
limited to white people.
But to say white privilege doesn't exist
from a historical context,
to me, respectfully absurd.
- Something that I
learned about recently is
the privilege that exists
in the medical field,
specifically relating
to the birthing process
in giving epidurals.
There was a study that's
recently, or was debunked,
that said Black people have
a higher tolerance for pain,
which then has been falsely used by people
who help support births in being hesitant
to provide the epidurals for
Black women giving birth.
A lot of women die in childbirth.
I don't know the exact statistics.
- Three times more likely,
Black women are to die.
- Thank you.
The fact that I will be taken seriously,
more seriously than a
Black woman in my place,
if I should be giving birth at some point,
I see that as just an absolute privilege.
My name is Bryn and I just graduated
and I'm currently getting hours
to becoming a licensed therapist.
As a therapist, in school,
we're taught to approach things
with what's called cultural humility.
Cultural humility is being curious.
And instead of trying
to have all the answers,
working collaboratively with the client
to kind of understand
where they're coming from.
- [Moderator] I have been
fetishized for my race.
- You know, the standard one.
"You're pretty for a Black girl."
I'm like, that's not a compliment.
That's so weird to say.
And one of the go-to pickup lines for men,
they're like, "Oh my God, what are you?"
I'm like, this is not cute.
I'm tired of having this conversation.
This is lame.
Yes, I know I have green eyes, hazel eyes.
Like, let's move on.
- I think Black women are, in particular,
just extremely sexualized and fetishized.
Every day I go out,
I'm making sure that my
outfit is, you know, okay,
because I don't wanna
draw certain attention.
The way I wear my hair,
if it's in an Afro,
if it's in puffs, if it's in braids,
I'm gonna get treated differently.
Yeah, every single day, something happens.
- So there's a form of
positive anti-Semitism
where Jews are perceived
as being put together,
coming from money, being doctors, lawyers.
And you know, women are attracted
to those sort of things.
And also, too, like all
Jewish men are circumcised.
Some women have that preference.
So I've definitely experienced it.
But I feel like it's a sort
of subtle, trivial thing.
Like it never really bothered me?
But it's occurred nonetheless.
- Yeah, I've had experiences
in high school, college,
you know, people ask me
to stop me, mainly women,
"Oh, are you Egyptian?"
"Are you Black and this?"
or "Black and that?"
It's always Black and something else.
And I let them know what
I am, and they be like,
"Ooh, that's exotic," or
something crazy, you know?
My name is Dino, and I'm biracial.
I don't want people to think
that I'm like split between
being Black or white.
I'm acknowledge that I'm
mixed and I'm biracial.
But for the most part growing up,
I was always considered Black.
I considered myself Black.
My family did as well.
So I don't think we should
live in a color-blind society.
But I also don't think
we should stay stuck
and feel like we can't move
forward and still thrive
and accomplish things
because of our skin color
and where we live in America.
- I would just have a question
for everyone who stepped forward.
I'm just curious, how
that's like, what's it like?
- Exhausting.
- It sounds exhausting.
- I think Black women historically
have a really interesting
relationship with desirability.
Culturally it seems we're not desired.
And then when we are,
we're being fetishized,
so it's like, okay, we're
usually not desired,
but now we are.
Am I supposed to lean
into this fetishization?
- I think just being a woman,
we deal with certain things every day.
Specifically being a Black
woman and being fetishized,
it's interesting because if I,
especially in my industry,
'cause I'm there to work
and be professional,
I'm just super professional
and I don't give any
attention that at all,
that kind of energy,
then I'm an angry Black woman.
So I think that it's just really-
- You can't win.
- It does feel like that, so, yeah,
that you can't win sometimes.
- And there's also a flip side to it.
It's like, for me, specifically,
I'm light-skinned amongst
majority dark-skinned people.
And people deem me or
deem light-skinned people
as a certain way, as
either weaker or less than.
Or just like, okay, you're lighter than,
so when we're so pro-Black
that we're never gonna
consider you as one of us.
You're just other.
- A lot like touches
just on beauty standards
in the Black community,
and that's colorism.
Like I've even been told,
"You're beautiful, you're not Black."
It's just like these little things.
- Oh yeah.
- Or, you must be mixed
with something, right?
- Yes.
- My name's Christina, and I'm biracial.
I have been fetishized
for the color of my skin
on both sides.
Black men will be really into
me because I'm light-skinned.
Or other men who are not
Black might be into me
because I am that Black girl,
but maybe I'm not too Black.
And that, for whatever
reason, is appealing.
Being deemed as exotic or something other
is just very problematic.
And that plays into a
lot of issues of colorism
within the Black community at large.
- [Moderator] We need reparations
for the Black community.
- I don't think people need
like individualized paychecks.
Like I don't think that's gonna like work.
But I think pouring funds into communities
who could really use
it, building jobs there,
more education there,
like more opportunities would do so much.
That's how I see it should be.
- Any time that Black
communities in the US
tried to pull themselves
up by the bootstraps,
they were attacked.
Like I think it was in
Tulsa, they bombed the city?
Black Wall Street, it
was completely destroyed.
So again, something needs to be done.
- When the Civil War ended,
there was a representative from Ohio.
I can't remember his name.
But he was a radical Republican
and advocated for the phrase,
"40 acres and a mule for
every emancipated slave."
So there was supposed to be reparations.
And there never was.
And I think especially as a Jewish person,
I mean, Jews received
reparations for the Holocaust
and are still receiving that.
And in my mind, there's no amount of money
that will ever undo the
wrong by the Holocaust.
All the money in the world
will never make it right.
But I think the idea and
principle of reparations is good.
Logistically, I don't
know how it would happen.
- I just wanted to say
the reason I stayed back
was because I wasn't entirely sure
what was meant by reparations.
But your example of the Holocaust,
I would say that I agree.
- Some other reason, when
I think of reparations,
I think of something
similar to a stimulus check.
My worry is with the lack
of financial literacy,
will we actually make strides.
That's my, so I would love
the idea of investing money
into programs in underserved communities,
something like that.
But I do have a fear that
even if we did have the money,
without that generational knowledge
of how to take care of our finances,
that it would just deplete
and defeat the purpose.
- But even if that were to happen, though,
I still think that that would
still be the right step.
You know, we'll give these
people the funds, or whatever.
We'll give them our promise.
And if they float or sink
or whatever, that's on them.
At least we as a country
took the right step.
- I'm all for money
going to the community.
I am for that,
because the communities right
now are the way they are
because of things in the past.
But to give out checks
to individual people,
there's a difference between
learning from the past
and then still getting
caught up in the past.
I mean, if I had a time machine,
I could go back in time and be like,
hey, you never gave us
the 40 acres and a mule.
I would be all for that
and I would be on that
for the people who were affected
and actually went through slavery.
But in today's age, like
no one's experienced it
and gone through it.
Yes, communities are taking
hit by that, but I never-
- You don't think your
ancestors experienced slavery?
- I think they do, but I haven't.
I've never been in it,
so why should I get a
check from somebody else
who never put.
You should be going
way, way, like way back.
- So what about the people
who are the descendants
of the slave owners who are still reaping
the financial benefits of your ancestors
who slaved in those fields,
for literally generation after generation?
You don't think that during that time,
your great-grandfather could
have been building a business
that could be flourishing by now,
and you would have a
multimillion-dollar franchise,
as they do off the backs of others?
You don't think that deserves
some rectification for you
in the present time?
- To be honest, no, because again,
it's something that happened in the past.
Again, I haven't experienced it.
I'm doing fine right now, I'm doing fine.
And I'm not going to be all upset
over somebody else's ancestors
who I don't even know who
enslaved my ancestors.
I don't need it.
I have no reason to have it.
- So for me, personally,
I'm not upset about it,
but I do feel my grandfather, on his side,
they were the first family
in the state of Texas
who actually filed for reparations.
And for me, I'm succeeding
in spite of that.
But to this gentleman's point,
when the government says,
"Hey, we're gonna do a thing,"
obviously the government
in itself saw the weight
and the error of wrong, just
as the German government did.
I think if I wanna buy 90 gold
chains, that's my business.
I think it would be unfortunate.
But I think if I'm entitled to something,
I think it should be in the same fashion
that the people of Jewish descent got it.
that the people that are Japanese got it.
So you might think it doesn't affect you.
But overall, I think we
have been greatly impacted
by slavery, even up to current.
I just choose not to focus on it nonstop
so it doesn't become
something that holds me back.
But I definitely think it's something
that we're entitled to.
- Thank you.
- Great, guys.
(applauding)
(panelists talking over each other)
- Thank you.
(pensive, enlightening music)